today's video is sponsored by aura and
we're really excited to introduce them
to you because they are basically like
the swiss army knife of identity
protection do you know that identity
theft is the fastest growing crime in
america with there being a new victim
every 14 seconds you need someone
watching your back and that is where
aura comes in or is identity theft
protection fraud monitoring password
management anti-virus and even a vpn
that's a lot aura combines all that into
one easy to use time saving app which is
great for us because we want to spend
our time making fun content for you you
might already have one of these services
but if you don't have all the tools it'd
be like locking the front door but
leaving the back door wide open which is
absolutely a synth aura is making it
simple to try out their identity
protecting services with a two week free
trial right now at aura.com tv sits the
link to protecting yourself and your
family from cynical identity stealers is
in the description below
[Music]
[Music]
oh marvel we send you for not having
moon knight in the intro to his own show
and you respond by putting him in the
intro to miss marvel so did you also put
miss marvel in the intro to your miss
marvel tv show i don't think so now i
must marvel that marvel missed the
marvelous miss marvel in marvel's miss
marvel making marvel's miss marvel intro
marvel s listen kamala thor was clearly
still rocking his thunder gut during the
battle for earth so i don't appreciate
the revisionist godbod representation
and the resulting body image pressure
but also what's up with his evil eyebrow
angry thorman giantsbane face but the
conspiracies commence because that is
not thor 616.
stapling in enemies oofy doodah bits
captains
i love this but my eyes are hurting and
my jump cuts need therapy why is the
podcast start a rectangle three thousand
by three thousand scott three thousand
by three thousand having two documents
with the same title on your desktop mere
inches away from each other unrealistic
representations of upload time for
videos remember new episodes drop every
wednesday unrealistic content
expectations don't let the content beast
eat you alive kamala or else you might
find yourself sitting in front of a
computer trying desperately to stay
relevant and funny while delivering five
pieces of content a week and wondering
where the last decade went you know just
as an example this wayward string it
beckons me it asks for cutting it asks
for pulling just take care of it kamala
please don't forget to look at the
mirrors every 15 seconds at least 15
seconds five to eight seconds is the
recommended standard for checking your
car's mirrors and an overprotective mom
would absolutely know that
you've seen this student driver crashes
into a car that just happens to be the
car of their instructor cliche so many
times i'm pretty sure you didn't even
need to have him say that's my car when
we were well aware of that the moment it
happened 10 seconds earlier marvel
continued showing us the new york city
skyline but not giving us any info on
the current state or ownership of
avengers tower i've read the guidebook
to toxic fandom and it clearly states
you owe us every piece of information
that we ask for so spill i get it high
school sucks for most people but does
every single coming of age tale ever
told need to hit us over the head with
this forced never-ending lineup of
consecutive cringe encounters the second
our protagonist walks through the door
no no no
putting the nose before bruno's name in
your encanto reference
i'm sorry i really do love you you're
also apparently clairvoyant because
that's the only way you would have known
kamala already knew about the driving
test bet the entire school seems to be a
sort of billboard for information and
there are zero ticks drawn on the
posters in a high school impossible very
funny very talented surely the art
teacher can look past the tento horns
and recognize and appreciate the
artistry then you're gonna look yourself
in the mirror and you're gonna ask
yourself kamala who is that girl i see
staring
straight back at me choosing reflection
instead of i'll make a man out of you i
know fantasy's fun fantasy is really fun
but right now
i need you to pull yourself together
and join reality this is get your head
out of the clouds kid cliche so hard
right now i have expect the thing to pop
around the corner and ponder his big
strong hands before kamala flies away on
the luck dragon from chongqi it's not
gonna be another first avenger con ever
again oh yes the shortsightedness of
youth the first isn't always the most
exciting or memory worthy trust me i'm
sorry is he airbrushing a costume in a
convenience store so can we stop acting
like your mom is darth vader referencing
encounter mulan and star wars within
five minutes of each other if we get a
national geographic reference in the
next five minutes i'm calling disney
plus bingo why ride through someone's
ball game certainly there are roads that
you can stay on i mean maybe not for the
sweet cinematic shot we have going on at
the moment but in real life there's no
reason to bike through is this from nani
there must be things for the key one
thing i'm really loving in this show is
the cultural immersion guessing most
people don't know what about pocky is
and the show doesn't care to explain it
we just move on because it's normal with
the characters and that's that it's rare
to feel invited into a new cultural
experience and not have everything over
explained to the point of distraction
[ __ ] love this they charge you for
extra thoughts on how long guys yes the
halal guys is a real place and yes i'm
adding us in because it looks delicious
and the closest one is currently 400
miles away from me but no one here seems
to be addressing is that if bruno just
made them this and is showing them how
it works then he must have also either
bought and installed them smart lights
throughout the entire house without
their knowledge or hacked into their
electricity at the source
switch to sports channel can zuzu read
minds because i don't care what
television package you have you've got
more than one sports channel this would
be like saying zuzu tell that story
about the time i embarrassed myself so
immensely i had to move to a new city
zuzu's gonna need a few more details to
narrow it down knock please right always
knock i don't care who you are or who
you think is or isn't on the other side
doors are shut for a reason adam
connecting your messaging app to your
starfield projector so that everyone can
see your text on your ceiling stopping
in the middle of the road to check your
phone
i don't know which is more convenient
this full-length rope just happened to
be sitting right there or that her mom's
suspicion meter doesn't go off
immediately and keep us from the
inevitable and already tiresome
misunderstanding gets worse conversation
honestly these she-hulk promotions are
getting a bit out of control at least
the effects look better here though
maybe on the roof in ten and she does
meaning somehow her parents were super
okay with her biking to see her buddy at
night just after a dramatic and
emotional family fall out i just don't
get the impression they would be okay
with that my mom my teachers mr wilson
he prefers gabe kamala
oh bruno corelli corporations i like it
has a nice ring to it no that says b
corelli it rhymes that's why it has a
nice ring to it
kamala please tell bruno the zuzu is
possessed by the evil gin if you were
gonna do the actual light bulb turns on
above a character's head when they have
an idea cliched did you really have to
shove it down our ocular cavities by
adding the animation as well we get it
you've seen a mel brooks movie deadpool
effectively destroyed the hero landing
for good six years ago and even the mcu
mocked it in black widow so i don't care
if this three-point landing is done
seriously for jokes or even a meta
commentary all three things have been
done better elsewhere so maybe just stop
doing them i'll sneak back into my room
just before my dad comes in at 9 22 p.m
that is a very specific time for your
dad to come into your room does it mean
something is there something you're
trying to tell us about september 22nd
the salem witch trials had their final
executions on september 22nd that's it
it's clear kamala will be accused of
witchcraft by the end of the season and
stand trial where she-hulk and matt
murdock will defend her quit making your
easter eggs so obvious marvel all this
and that's her note really did she
casually draw this during science class
has everyone gone home for the day and
they lingered for the chalkboard and
somehow the teacher was super fine with
that and that is why the salamanders are
almost extinct in pakistan i think we're
supposed to feel for kamala here who
seems bored by this conversation but
animal extinction is interesting and
important what's avenger con when you
could be educated on amphibian
conservation
this is supposed to be the real world
right kabbalah literally just did a head
first dive to grab a branch on a tree
two stories in the air as if this is
just a normal thing teenagers do when
sneaking out of the house why would she
do this is she aware she's wearing about
six layers of plot armor also a
convenient pile of leaves that still
wouldn't break the fall enough to do
much is convenient stopping to observe
the bus you're desperately trying to
catch instead of continuing the process
of desperately trying to catch it the
leg hiker looks to our camera and i am
unreasonably annoyed by it
tough look for vision here the memorial
wall only including tony and natasha is
pretty harsh don't let wanda see it she
might kidnap your entire town and force
you into slave labor for her own
fantasies only to be redeemed because
she maybe learned her lesson for a few
seconds before a movie needed her to be
super evil again and we wouldn't want
something like that to happen kamala's
phone goes off and says motion detected
and then it shows us the dining room
where her parents already are how is
that thing not going off every few
seconds look show if you just needed to
remind us that kamal is here without her
parents permission you could have just
had her check the camera without the
notification like a normal creepy
teenager who has cameras set up to spy
on their parents people who don't
realize there are flashes on when it
doesn't need to be kamala sets her
helmet down so the badass gloves touch
the disgusting bathroom floor who does
that people who need an excuse to lose
them for a plot point that's who last
call for the captain marvel cosplay
competition it is not what are you
wearing
dumb red carpet questions
[Applause]
oh sure bruno's been into kamala in this
whole process this entire time but just
at the moment magic stuff happens he's
all like i think i'll stare at the
people on the stage non-stop now so the
audience will believe that this means
i'm not seeing this and that will stand
in for the rest of this massive crowd
who also is somehow not noticing this
yep that's exactly what unsure and
nervous humans do they go directly to
the center of the stage and walk to the
very front it's basic psychology look it
up i'd like to make it clear that this
not spherical ant-man noggin will land
in water with the antenna parts facing
forward making it difficult to roll and
almost zero forward momentum and yet
somehow will roll a hundred feet through
this warehouse crashing into tables
demolishing a giant brick wall and still
having enough force left to give head to
a load-bearing support beam physic much
movie
zoe survives this bet you'll be a little
thor tomorrow
i'm sorry just please continue watching
to the end anyway it appears as though
our heroes are panic pedaling home after
a disturbing event one would think they
would ditch the light up attention
grabbing costumes to seem less
suspicious but no maybe the first
indicator that kamala's been busted is
that her parents closed the [ __ ]
window she left open
[Music]
where have you been how has kamala not
check the camera i know she was
preoccupied at the event but she
couldn't have taken a second on the bike
ride home to see how things were going
at the home front or do you want to be
some you know this cosmic
head in the clouds person she asks while
standing in a room that is a vibrant
shrine to a cosmic woman flying
headfirst through the clouds you did 17
of these earlier we do not need another
one bring her in at this point i'm just
going to send a post-credits scene in a
marvel production cliche and move on
thanks again to aura for sponsoring
today's video ora monitors the dark web
for your personal information gives you
near real-time alerts on suspicious
credit inquiries and keeps your browsing
history safe and encrypted with their
vpn all from one easy to use app imagine
trying to log into your email one day
only to see the password changed hours
ago and then you start getting
notifications of activity from your bank
credit cards crypto accounts etc that's
a scary and unfortunate reality for many
people but it doesn't have to be yours
use our link aura.com tv synths and
utilize a free two-week trial link is in
the description who is that girl i see
sorry that's the lion king but the point
still stands i can like wear cakes
there's a scientific study that shows
that if you stand like this in superhero
pose you will not only feel more
confident you will perform measurably
better that's the plan got it i'm not
sure this plan will work how likely is
it i'm gonna find it there when i get
back oh i'd say you have a point zero
zero zero one percent chance so you're
telling me there's a chance
did you ever have the feeling you was
being
watched
what goes up must come down